a lot of valley restaurants are
struggling tonight trying to stay afloat
with only 25 percent capacity
more than ever they need our community
support sally jaramillo shows us changes
to two latino owned restaurants
and how tamale sales this week will
hopefully keep them in business
before the 25 percent is fantastic but
when the
six solar putting the the restriction
about 25 percent is very difficult to
make money
havana grill owner sergio perez has been
open
for 16 years making changes to stay open
i need to pay the employee i need to pay
the rent i need to pay
all the bills to my pocket his priority
is keeping his employees
i'm making the beautiful cuban bakery
for
use the space because about two thousand
feet
i don't use anymore perez opened a
bakery three months ago
inside you can find cuban pastelitos and
cakes
the people like you know it's new and
tis the season for tamales
a must this time of year for the
majority of latin american countries
the tamales you have pork inside
is garlic and the
the corn i need to grain
put in grain and later on putting
cooking together the pour
and the season inside the tamale maria
guadalupe gil owns casa don juan open
now for 25 years specializing in tamales
during the holidays
all the tamales of mexican that's a very
traditional on this time
and we're trying to when you open the
door you like to feel
you are in mexico and enjoy the fiesta
she has also had to cut staff from 75 to
about 25 employees
but she has made sure the passion for
making those tamales
remains the same chicken with the green
sauce and we have a pork with the red
sauce
and also we have the cheese and
jalapenos
sally jaramillo 8 news now by the way
both havana grill and casa don juan
tamales are made from scratch
they both have delivery options for the
holidays and they say despite the
difficulties they are thankful and
hopeful